i
[Música]
y
colombia está en su segundo mes de paro
nacional unas protestas sin precedentes
si bien la reforma tributaria retirada
ahora por el gobierno de iván duque fue
la mecha del estallido social las
manifestaciones han sido un catalizador
de frustraciones y problemáticas
estructurales que sufre gran parte de la
población colombiana en el segundo país
más desigual de américa latina' las
movilizaciones sociales han estado
marcadas por una fuerte represión
policial que ha causado la muerte de al
menos 43 personas según la ong local
temblores y en más de 3400 heridos
aunque el gobierno entrega un balance
diferente tan sólo el viernes pasado 13
personas fallecieron en la ciudad de
cali epicentro de las protestas
duke está siendo criticado por la falta
de contundencia a la hora de condenar
los abusos policiales y por postergar la
visita de organismos internacionales
finalmente la próxima semana la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos
llegará a colombia para verificar los
hechos ocurridos durante las masivas
manifestaciones
[Música]
había cientos de miles de ellos en todo
brasil el pasado fin de semana los
opositores al presidente jefferson ago
realizaron la mayor manifestación desde
que comenzó la pandemia esta
demostración de fuerza en varias
ciudades del país tuvo lugar a raíz de
una serie de revelación en la comisión
de investigación del senado sobre la
mala gestión de la pandemia por el
gobierno lo que convertía a brasil en el
segundo país del mundo con más fallecido
por la pandemia según más reciente
encuesta de opinión sólo el 24 por
ciento de los brasileños apoyan el
presidente revolucionario nunca el
presidente de extrema derecha tuvo está
abajo en los sondeos los centros también
dan como claros favoritos en las
elecciones de 2022 el ex presidente lula
da silva según los analistas políticos
está manifestación podría marcar el
inicio de una nueva fase de estabilidad
política a sólo 18 meses de las
elecciones presidenciales
[Música]
unai ebook l conocido como el presidente
millennial del salvador llega a su
segundo año de gestión con buenas
valoraciones por parte de la población
según diversas encuestadoras la buena
aceptación de bukele se debe en gran
parte a la disminución de los homicidios
en un país que años atrás fue
considerado uno de los más violentos del
mundo sin embargo la sociedad civil
también de alarma en algunas acciones
que califican de autoritarias y que
buque le ha impulsado excusándose en su
alta popularidad como la incursión
militar en la asamblea legislativa en
febrero de 2020 y su respaldo a la
reciente decisión de la nueva
legislatura oficialista de destituir a
los magistrados de la sala de lo
constitucional y al fiscal general de la
república a esto se suman diversos
señalamientos por presuntos actos de
corrupción cometidos por miembros de su
gabinete todo lo anterior ha desatado
algunas manifestaciones dentro del país
en rechazo al mandatario las cuales a
pesar de hacer poco numerosas podrían
ser reflejos de una disminución en el
optimismo de la ciudadanía con respecto
al desempeño del gobernante
[Música]